so what do you think about the Austin
comedy scene
it is incredible
yeah it's very good I think
we're very lucky to be here I didn't
plant I didn't plan for this I moved to
Austin for a job
as a engineer and then it happened
for Austin to be the scene now in the
world
yeah I think it's crazy how amazing it
is because there's
it's not like LA or New York it's like
LA or New York visited a smaller City
and it has all the benefits of the
smaller City
and then none of the negative parts of
it
to LA
yeah la is great because there's so many
people there and they're all doing
something unique and special and just
around that and it feeds you
but I think it can be bad because it can
also like exploit you they know what you
need and they know what you're willing
to give up what I've heard from La is
that every everyone is trying to be like
an you know like a famous person or
something like that yeah but here you
you see your regular people everywhere
you go
yeah but I I've never been totally so I
really don't know
yeah la is
like
its own image of itself is like
consuming itself it's like a cyclical
Loop and it's just an efficient use of
energy where they're just only thinking
about themselves and
uh
yeah I mean it's good to be in a scene
where you can
be a part of like
Humanity instead of like just a specific
City
yeah I mean I think uh it's good to be
in Austin I think it's really hard to
tell what it's going to turn into the
comedy club just opened
yeah
um
seems like for guys that are not
[Music]
you know either working at the
mothership or are not like famous yet
kind of like Mr hands came over here so
you talk about yourself yeah Smiles
works there no I know so I'm talking
about myself I'm gonna say something
self-deprecating no I'm talking about
myself and other comics
that are thinking that moving to Austin
is gonna you know
this is what I'm trying to say I think
it's gonna be harder than what what most
Comics think about like getting into
like the mothership and things like that
yeah oh yeah that stuff I think will be
hard but I think the the cool part about
Austin is that there's like you can the
I think the coolest thing about the seed
is that there's like there's like
there's like independent shows that get
like really good crowds which you don't
really yeah like Bianca Lucas you know
yeah like just shows that are like just
you know just somebody's putting it on
and it's like you'll still you can get
like a hundred people come out to shows
like going out to shows is not an easy
thing yeah I think like some uh cities
are better at it than others and Austin
had already a great live scene for sure
like the audience was ready to go out to
see shows yeah yeah yeah I mean you can
get like a like in New York you can't do
that you can't just do like a you're not
doing like a hundred people like show
yeah unless it's in like a club or
something because they're they're like
why don't I just go to Broadway if I'm
gonna go out I don't want to go out and
see
something that's not going to be as good
yeah
but here they have no choice yeah like
spider house or the like and there's so
many music venues that are like
not being used
you know yeah more the more comics that
we have here also more comics are
putting up more shows more more mics
more there's more opportunities
yeah like it's way I feel like it's
easier to get
good here
then like like New York you get there's
like mics you gotta like pay for and
stuff I really wanted to you could do
six mics in one night here
yeah yeah you wouldn't develop like uh
toxicity or like agua
grumpiness that you get in New York or
L.A you know yeah and also unlike uh
unlike a bigger city
you can just even if you like on like a
night where you like just bomb your dick
off
at least you could go home to like a a
decently spacious apartment
you know you're just like man I feel
like a loser I'm never I'm never gonna
be good anything in New York you go into
your broom closet
go to your closet you go in your closet
you go I'm a [__] I'm gonna shoot
myself in the head
it's like the perfect setting for it
it's here at least here at least you're
like I'm a failure but at least like
look at all these dogs and the people
here are so friendly like people want to
hang out here like they might not be
friendly to you but like everyone has
like a group of people and people are
more willing to like go I don't know if
it's everywhere since the pandemic and I
also think everyone who is sort of like
trying to party and like get to meet
other people came here because this was
the only place that was open so from all
the cities everyone I know is from
another city all the people that were
like down to hang out the most came here
oh they're lonely yeah
we're sad and also you bomb you can go
you can go freaking paddle board for
like 15 bucks I mean that's that's a
good way to feel better you know it's a
beautiful city you just go you can drive
to it and not pay for parking in like
you know
you could just drive 15 minutes and park
and you're on a lake I mean it's pretty
awesome
it's a great City for
yeah look at the weeds here
it's flowers
did you move here because of Joe Rogan
are you sure you get a job
are you talking to me oh not you you
were here before yeah I was here before
coven I mean I moved here because of Joe
Rogan and Tony Hinchcliffe yeah directly
nice well I didn't move here because of
them but I stayed here
because of them that makes sense that
helps I was planning about moving to New
York
yeah and then uh when covet happened and
everything and then they you know killed
Tony moved here and then Europe and
announced that he was gonna move here I
was like yeah I'm just gonna stay here
yeah if you don't have any particular
like emotional connection or like you
don't want it that bad and it's like
this is just as good now
you needed about to move if you already
had your roots you knew the city you
knew people here you had a job here
so what do you think about
a
[Music]
the open mic URL and oh yeah how it went
you're so high
I already asked you you know but really
like if you could do like also like
three shows in one night if you really
want to and you know the people and you
know
like Austin is pretty cool to stand up
um I feel like you can pretty much go
from one place to another and like you
know you'll be there in 10 minutes
um
it's nice it's nice it's very nice
um you were also here before miles right
yeah yeah
same same thing enchiladas Cantina
Micheladas shout out Micheladas
the patio patio show one of the best one
of the best semi indoor shows
that was the first place that opened
during covert wow would all go there on
Wednesday I think
that's crazy
though what happened to it did they
cancel it
to 36. I think they couldn't handle uh
they didn't I don't think they were
getting enough money from the they had
the space was gigantic the rest the
restaurant they had it was like yeah it
it was probably like
like a thousand people could be in that
restaurant because the balcony because
the balcony area is seated like
like two to three hundred people yeah
yeah and it was like 20 comedians yeah
yeah there's always yeah there's nobody
at their space as far apart as possible
the bartender whenever they had a
bartender upstairs he would hit like he
hated us because people would also order
food
and uh I just remember head tips for
that yeah you just remember him like
yelling from their back like
so I want another someone nachos
and he was like angry
[Music]
I uh
I thought it was a great mic
I was usually late sometimes they did it
downstairs
yeah they did it downstairs a couple
times and there were those grackles
that were super loud I would interrupt
this set
crackles
fat nurses
oh yeah these people are just like oh we
just wanted to eat Mexican food
sorry stupid yeah you're about to listen
to
you're about to listen to 40 of Austin's
newest residence
[Music]
their opinion about rape and
race I know that would be like regular
human beings trying to have freaking
chips and salsa and queso
and we'll be like what is in that queso
come
is that why you like it so much they're
like Jesus
[Music]
they're like saving lives because
they're nurses
took us 20 minutes to find parking
I think he's 20 minutes to find parking
we get in and we get inside finally get
our food this guy
keeps saying I'm eating come he keeps
call me a [__] eating [__] about to find
another parking spot go to Iron Cactus
no yeah
we can't escape it too because he's got
a microphone
yeah it was upstairs
but it was upstairs is just us
and like occasionally a group would come
up you know like because because the
waiters hated us there they wouldn't
tell anybody yeah they would never like
go up if you like comedy yeah yeah they
would give you like Corona without a
lime you know
yeah I was like when I went there again
I was like I'm not I try like make sure
that they knew I wasn't there for the
comedy
yeah dude I was uh I was trying to uh we
tried to put this like sign up to like
he's like can we put a sign outside to
let people know that there's stand-up
going on upstairs they're like no like
we don't want anyone to know yeah that's
so funny that they I I like are
supportive enough to have it but not
supportive enough to let people know
about it yeah yeah what's the point of
it then
I think uh they were getting at least
five beverage sold to the comics
yeah the comics don't really buy a lot
of stuff because a lot of them are too
poor yeah yeah they can't afford Like a
downtown restaurant's prices yeah
I mean it they had a menu they had a
menu where like they didn't put the
prices on the menu that's like you know
it's like yeah it's too expensive yeah
yeah you'd be like can I get a beer and
also do you have free chips and salsa
I'll do two baskets please
oh my God
the people in Texas Drive crazy yeah but
not as crazy as Miami yeah people drive
crazy everywhere dude well in Texas I
feel like it's more of like aggression
like you can't do anything to stop me I
have a gun in Miami I feel like it's
like hey I'm partying [__] you Miami's
again yeah they think they're driving
perfect
it's a mix of like third world poverty
driving and yeah I know Miami is a
Latino culture everybody's just you know
driving crazy you know putting a sign or
sign function by chismo how do you call
that when you when you change your lines
signal way changes and turn signals
right
but I feel like in Houston people drive
a little worse than Austin
yeah there's more competition
more yeah
more accurate
no I don't know about that but yeah yeah
I feel I feel with Austin it's more just
people are
I feel like mostly it's just people
being dumb yeah it's like if somebody's
just like not looking
yeah they're taking their time they're
just like like all the times like when
we were just driving just now most of
the crazy stuff that happened was just
somebody
she's like I'm gonna go into this Lane
I'm not gonna look
yeah it's like all right
but I will say that the worst thing
about the driving I feel in Texas is
that people will try to run there's like
you can't they won't let you on to the
highway
or like off it yeah
like they want to let you get in front
of them to get off the highway or
something they're just like they're like
no this is my Lane
yeah
yeah because so many people try to cut
each other off that you're like
automatically programmed to not let
anyone in because so many people just
like
you know cut you off
so then when someone is trying to get on
it's like this whole meta game is [__]
where everyone's just trying to get as
much for themselves as possible yeah
also women are allowed to drive now
is that true
is it did Beto do that
they don't have to wear the shrouds
anymore we're back in the good old days
where we all drove horses
the horses drove themselves and that was
that was better
you can't do a
is that there's still like no abortion
rent
I feel like everybody chilled out about
that is there no abortion the whole
abortion ban thing remember that yeah
I feel like everybody just kind of
chilled out it's like six weeks
yeah I don't know I don't know if
anybody changed anything I don't think
it's that that present in anyone's life
no one is like getting abortions that
much where they're gonna notice
and then when it does happen it's like
to small enough number of people we're
we're not going to know about it until
they gain a critical mass yeah and then
once you have kids you're like I don't
want to be like I don't want you Billy
yeah so they're gonna like rationalize
themselves like oh it's I wanted him
yeah so then they're not gonna say
anything I feel like you know who's
getting abortions once you get an
abortion
it's kind of like when you start doing
this download comedy then everybody
around you is like you know the abortion
Community yeah they're like in the
Facebook group the abortion scene
yeah
that's Tammy she has like six abortions
yeah she's like respect she's an admin
of the Facebook group
no yeah we all respect her
yeah baby
she's got the whole U.N
I heard she did three abortions in one
day
legendary one for her two for her
systems all right
yeah I want to go on the road she's
going on the road doing abortions
it's like when you're buying a couch and
you're like oh everyone's buying a couch
right now yeah yeah same
it's like so important to have a
community
newborn babies
I wonder if all the aborted babies have
a community in heaven
in heaven or they just suck out of an
umbilical cord aborted babies go that
way
where did they put them
I think they use it to make another baby
that's gonna survive now
it's like goo
it's just like period can you imagine
heavy flow can you imagine God being oh
yeah right I guess you I guess you get
rid of it personally
that kind of sucks
yeah
I can't even reuse it
yeah give it to some Filipino guy and he
might eat it because they're into balut
yeah
maybe they
I think
nobody should be aborting but everybody
should be if you don't want the baby you
should be able to sell the organs and
stuff
that's your baby
you can't even sell it for parts because
why let our good heart go to waste you
know
what are you gonna do with it yeah give
it to it who are you gonna give it to
that it's a baby's heart yeah a lot of
babies a lot of infants need a heart
transplant
let's give it a little baby heart yeah
I don't think it's gonna happen yeah
they sell organs in the black market you
haven't seen this I don't think they
sell baby organs yeah I do
believe nobody wants baby organs
yeah unless you're gonna eat it
yeah somebody might eat it there's a
higher chance of somebody wanting to eat
a baby heart
then a baby heart getting flown
across the country dude I'm sure you can
they sell baby organs in the black
market I bet doctors just go ah she's
over I feel like most people just go
that's over no you haven't seen uh White
parents trying to fight for their
children's life
they'll do anything there's no baby
hearts out there
let me get a a heart from
these children in Thailand
if you had to get a heart right now
where would you go HEB HEB yeah what
would you do there they sell cow Kyle's
Hearts I think
yeah like a human heart if you had to
get kill a child no I wouldn't kill a
child well you need a heart for a child
so you need a child's heart yeah how
would you pick like the most you useless
child to kill the one that's gonna make
the least impact in the world no that's
this is very mean and dark I don't like
it anymore
oh you have limits that
I would go to like Mexico Mexico is the
closest
North Mexico is where all the poor
Mexicans are right
um I don't know but like like if you
wanted to get a heart like you know
legally you you could but it's gonna
cost like uh I think it's like
I don't know 10 million dollars five
million dollars something like that oh
my God but then in the black market you
could probably get it for like uh 20 000
you know like a Toyota Tacoma with like
70 000 miles where do they even keep the
hearts
the black market arts
if I had to guess I would say a freezer
big freezer
I have no idea
[Music]
is this do they need like fancy
equipment
to keep it beating yeah
so let's say you get like a brain it's
just like an evil hospital if you get
like a brain transplant from someone
from a baby from another country are you
gonna have thoughts and like
Taiwanese or whatever Taiwanese I bet
you will I bet you get I think you get
like little [__] all of a sudden you
get a Chinese heart you see a cat you're
like oh God that's so yummy
your stomach starts trembling a little
bit
no one's like eating only cats in China
I know are there somebody eating only
cats in China there's somebody eating
only cats in America no way there's
gotta be there's one person there's one
person that eats only cats yeah and he
has a certain type of cat that's nice oh
tabby yeah cats are smart though they
would figure it out they'd avoid that
house they'd be like that's the
boogeyman yeah we hunts them
cats like to have a territory they don't
move too far until you give them food
until you show them food with their
human intelligence we can get cats
forever yeah
well that's the thing is like what where
would the supply be you go like a year
and you wipe out the whole stray
population in your neighborhood
no you could you could do one cat a day
that's 365 Caps or you could probably do
now so you probably do uh one cat for
like two days
yeah I feel like I could eat
a cat every two days but I would have to
like it's like a rotisserie chicken I
imagine
like that amount of meat yeah it's kind
of stimulating
have you eaten a cat before no
I'm just talking about like from
touching them
they're all muscle
there's plenty of cats too you can
because you can also drive to the next
town
put out a couple traps
so you just like circle around like a
national forest
yeah you put out traps everywhere just a
little little snares how many diseases
do you think you'd get eating Stray Cats
every day
you definitely a toxoplasmosis
why you think
yeah if you're around that many cats
you're trapping them you're killing them
no we would do it with pigs and
yeah people raise pigs all the time
right but you're not killing pigs every
day in your home
no no you did but you would also go to
HEB and get by cats you know yeah
if it was popular to eat cats I know
there's a factory that would work you'd
be like I'll do two pounds of cotton
meat or whatever
what would be the best part of a cat
butt probably yeah probably the haunches
or the ribs the legs oh yeah like little
uh cat ribs like yeah like chicken bones
they have soft bellies so it's probably
the
like cat bacon
do cats let you touch their belly that's
right that's what I'm saying they've got
soft bellies they don't like they don't
like being touched there so it's
probably like pretty tasty stuff
what if like I feel like chicken is the
most popular meat
yeah like people eat so much chicken
just because there's more of it but if
it wasn't like if if it didn't exist
I'm just wondering what animal doesn't
exist that we're not aware of
that is better than chicken oh what
animal can take over chicken or it could
be more popular than chicken because I
know I know but you kale like the kale
of meat
yeah I feel like that maybe goats well
definitely fish I feel like the kale of
meat is a lamb
what about crickets
yeah that is definitely the account of
protein yeah I should create actually
because I think kale tastes like [__]
yeah I hate kale it's too tough Kelly's
worst let's just salt the [__] out of it
and make it crunchy yeah he got popular
out of nowhere I fell yeah I don't I
never ate kale a day in my life and then
all of a sudden it's everywhere yeah so
I mean for influencer started the whole
thing
it's like what we eat is like a drug or
like a little little
trip to a theme park yeah bro like if
I'm starving and someone goes yeah I
have some kale I'll be like I'd rather
die that [__] sucks
I mean if you ate it you'd probably
still die
true
kill sucks dude give me spinach
[__] with spinach all day
now I like spinach on
omelettes
on what
omelettes omelettes yeah omelettes like
uh with some like uh goat cheese or
something oh yeah and some mushrooms and
maybe some onions
yeah spinach is good
it's a good it's a good replacement of
kale I don't like uh spinach by itself
though when it's wet
you just eat a lot of it
yeah
I think kale was like Hey we're gonna
try something new with our mouths
everyone we're doing this new thing yeah
try to make your mouth feel like my
mouth
someone told me that kale acts as a
sponge
to your
digestive system or whatever and it like
cleans the walls or something
everything does that yeah I don't know I
think they're lying
reach my eyes in cold weather
kale sucks
I really want to talk about kale anymore
I don't want to give it the [__] air
time so what do you think about the
newest comedy club and Austin Texas
probably the country
I don't think the world comedy's really
taken off in other countries it's crazy
yeah
it is crazy that every country
or most countries have a really like
they have a comedy scene
yeah like there's Comics there that they
go every night and they perform and
people laugh and you need a community
it's not like woodworking you can't just
do it alone yeah so then it's like oh we
can tap into everyone who's doing comedy
at the same time yeah yeah
but I you know I started my I do my [__]
do scale talk anyways I did my first
open mic in Shanghai and over there for
the number of people that live in
Shanghai they only had I think
like 20 Comics you know yeah English
yeah it's an American thing people in
Asia don't want to hear someone talk but
they also they also do stand up in um
Singapore in uh Chinese
yeah some Comics that are bilingual they
were doing it in both
yeah I mean uh did you ever do Chinese
comedy
I don't speak Chinese
or some no never mind oh yeah I abort
this conversation hey did you try to do
Chinese comedy I was gonna do a very
hacky joke where I went with some pots
and pants on stage and I just smash them
on the ground
[Laughter]
is that what you think Chinese people do
to talk to each other no that's what I
that's a hockey joke about
they would say it's a Spanish joke they
would say how do they name a Chinese
baby they throw pots and pants down the
stair yeah and then they record the
sound and that's the name
[Music]
[Laughter]
because in Spanish everybody's like a
common joke you know that's an American
joke too oh yeah yeah there you go I
think it's uh
it sort of makes sense but I mean it
turns to like comedy
because you're putting together whole
sentences it's not just one word
but yeah I mean I think it's great that
everyone's doing it now they're like hey
we can talk to each other we can try to
entertain each other instead of like
just being bored yeah all the time
it's like an art form oh yeah
and it's so weird because they're
growing up knowing about American stand
up so it's like oh I'll never be as good
as that as long as I live
so there's like a almost self-self uh
limiting mechanism to their comedy where
they're like oh Americans do the good
comedy but I specialize in the cheap
stupid comedy
so it's like they're almost stunted in
their growth
when you say they who are you talking
about foreigners anyone who's not
American
I hear some people can't I feel like you
can can't you just Crush though just
doing some like
you could probably just Crush doing like
some unknown American Comics that's
really funny it's jokes yeah that's what
that French comedian did Dad a lot no
but he didn't do unknown Comics he did
like Jerry Seinfeld
which is crazy yeah you gotta start low
I was like you could do like Shane
Gillis in China just Crush
yeah
yeah like doing Jerry Seinfeld was
that's insane it's like he's like that's
French people for you it's like he's
like what you would think when you think
of stand-up comedy back then you know
like in the 2000s you're like who's the
best like who's the most famous stand-up
comedian
right now Jerry Seinfeld
yeah there's gonna be even some French
people that know him
it's like trying to copy a burger copy
McDonald's
it's like go for Arby's
that's a very complex example because
burgers are pretty much similar they all
have the same ingredients I don't have a
brand name oh name okay yeah
yeah like I remember when Abercrombie
and Fitch was like famous or whatever
they had a store in Venezuela and it was
Albert Crombie so like Albert
like with an ale like Al where Crombie
was this still one word
yeah it was exactly like Abercrombie &
Fitch but it was Albert Crombie and
Finch yeah and everything was fake but
with the same like you know moves and
everything yeah like knock off clothes
because like the people that make the
clothes are like
we could sell this to other people too
yeah and make more money for sure
yeah the first comic I saw ever was uh
run White
and Larry the Cable Guy and I saw them
on Comedy Central and I was living in
Venezuela
and they were performing in English with
subtitles in Spanish
and I was like oh that seems pretty cool
did you like it I loved it yeah
would you like more
um
so
it's it's not the same because I was I
was very young so I was just reading the
subtitles
so you know when you're younger I feel
like uh Larry the Cable Guy was funnier
because he's talking about farts and
[__] like that
but then I I started to like uh run
white uh more
oh my God that's so dangerous
yeah I mean uh that seems like a natural
transition it'd be weird if you went the
other way around if you're like a really
smart kid and then you grow up to be
like an idiot I did like that wrong why
it seemed like he could be like friends
with like my dad because he was like
drinking whiskey
[Music]
you know alcohol and cigar
I think I like
I like Ron White better
but I'm more impressed by Larry the
Cable Guy
like I used to not be impressed I found
out that he was a character like yeah
right three months ago yeah that's what
I'm saying it's like it's impressive
that he would he went around the country
like acting
but like still doing like funny jokes
he built an Empire he was doing he was
doing like a caricature
yeah you know it's like that's kind of
it's like for some reason I respect the
wrong way
um way
yeah I mean a lot of people can be
stupid
so he's gonna have a lot of competition
and it's like why do we choose this
stupid guy over any other stupid guy
where's the thing he's not stupid though
he's he's doing the character of being
stupid right which is
but he's like the Donald Trump of Comedy
like Donald Trump plays kind of like
even though he's a billionaire
speaks to like the poor average or
whatever yeah yeah it's like it's
impressive that he's like I was like
because you know because
he's really good at being stupid
yeah but he's not he's not even that
like the jokes are in it some of the
jokes aren't even that dumb it's about
like farts but it'll be like it'll be
like a pretty it's like that's a pretty
smart joke actually
Penny will also do I pooped out my
wiener
which is just that's just good clean fun
very smart that's his
Hot Pockets
but yeah they were so [__] popular
that they were playing them in Venezuela
so
I came up with like he's got like a fake
catch you know catchphrase and
everything it's like that's crazy yeah
yeah
I mean it is suppressive if you try to
be impressed by it
you could do that for anything
yeah
I don't know it's impressive dude
because he's not I was just like he's
not that guy
but he's just doing this he's doing this
act
yeah like it's like I'm like like I like
Ron White for stand up
but I'm like as far as like uh
a performance
you know like I feel like Larry the
Cable Guy's like that's like a
performance he's very commercial he's
he's like a product
yeah like like Runway run white uh Jeff
Foxworthy
they're like good they're just like good
comedians yeah
they're all legends
funny
all of them now Larry the Cable Guy he
was doing regular stand up before
yeah
but then he said that he was doing
voices and then that voice kind of like
people kept you know saying do that
voice you know and then that kind of
attempt that momentum it's an art form
to like speak to people's like
commonalities
like something that we all share and
like yeah this is what I
had nobody
whatever I think he I think he's more
impressive to me because it's like Ron
White and all the other guys they were
just doing stand up because they were
just good stand-up comedians and then
this guy probably wasn't that good at
stand-up comedy so he like created this
whole like method
to be like just as well liked as those
other guys yeah he he had to do like
create this whole
disguise like the voice the character
what this whole other person
so that he could
you know yeah he had to develop like the
most amazing crutches yeah it's like
would you rather see like yeah I'd say
like what would I I would I'd rather
watch a documentary on on the the rise
of Larry the Cable Guy
then I would like most other comedians I
think literally a cable guy recently
[Music]
like no that's what I'm saying it's like
a tragic it's kind of like a cool and
interesting story
like he did uh kill Tony this Monday
and he did he's doing stand-up still
like he's uh like I admire
um I mean I admire all of them but Ron
White he's still like going for it you
know yeah Jeff Foxworthy dropped out
oh yeah no I don't want I mean I'm not
saying I want a Baylor the Cable Guy I
just find his story more interesting
he's just more interesting though
because it's like he's like it's like he
did all this stuff and then he just
stopped you know what I mean miles I
think he must do
what's the uh
like I don't want to hear about the guy
that was just like
like Dave you know Dave Chappelle is
awesome I'm like like he's like one of
my favorite comedians
but it's like I'd much rather watch a
Larry the Cable Guy documentary
it's like what oh Dave Chappelle like
it's gonna be interesting but it's no
it's not even anywhere near as
interesting as the guy that changed his
entire persona
yeah
and the horrible things for fame it's
like the tiger king of comedy yeah he
did all it did so much just like for
fame and money
changed he sold his soul
yeah you want to hear the story of the
good Banker or do you want to hear the
Bernie Madoff story you know
Jeffrey Epstein you know it's like what
that what was that guy doing
maybe we should all just fake it until
we make it
nah
I mean would you rather drive a post
office mail truck until you die or be
Larry the Cable Guy if you have the
option
uh if you if you were happy as the post
office guy
same happiness level same happiness
alone
but not saying money though I would
choose the post office guy because you
guys are the Cable Guy you got to go
home yeah he has to deal with the hate
and the positivity yeah also you get to
check out all the cool new stamps God
loves you praise him that's so crazy
it's like positive in the first I was
like oh God bless me and it's like
praise him
[Laughter]
say why can't they just keep it positive
yeah why is he expecting something in
return yeah
I love you praise me
yeah they never really explain why
what does that do for him I think that's
the son was talking about it on stage
he's he's ego he's hurting Praise Him
that's how my dad acted
he's like why aren't you praising me you
praise God but you won't praise me like
they got a trump plate nice body to play
it's all [__] up
I don't know what they were they were
trying to say with that yeah the whole
it's I feel like people don't even
they're like they're saying they're
saying all these things
like I feel like religious people they
say all these things and then it's just
like you don't even know why though
they're like put God back in America
that sign said it's like what's but
what's that gonna do yeah tell us what
what you think that'll accomplish and
we'll just do that
It's like because then everybody will be
good it's like no they won't
oh yeah like the Spanish Inquisition
yeah it's like we you yeah it's like
look at history look at people you know
I mean but Hitler there's plenty there's
plenty of people you just you know that
go to church you know what I mean it's
like
or just like the Catholic church it's
just like what what are we talking about
I just don't get it well I get it but it
would be so much easier if it was just
like one religion either you're it or
you're not
but like if you look at like
christianism there's so many
christianism yeah Catholicism or
whatever
I went to a Catholic school and I don't
even
I don't remember yes it's like hey we're
all doing this right now
I mean that's how it was but now we're
like in a Multicultural Society so like
everyone's weird [__] is like I feel
like the Asians kind of were kind of
they were like the closest they've
gotten the closest to like
good religions yeah
we got kind of [__] up Christianity
got [__] up early
what do you mean like like the the
church like Catholic church had like was
like an actual body of like power
it was like it's like it got corrupted
it got corrupted way way earlier yeah
the church had an army of God yeah it's
like you give it you gave a guy an army
it's like they had no time to even like
get into like the philosophy they're
like all right let's use this Army yeah
what do you think Jesus Army get rich
what do you think why do you think they
started the whole uh celibate or
whatever you know the priest cannot be
married or because if you let them [__]
it just [__] everything up like then
like they have too much power oh
there's nothing worse than having man
like not coming for a couple days
that's dangerous
yeah
they didn't give a [__]
well they're good on their own though
I feel like God if you don't come for a
while
and you're only in your own and you're
by yourself you're fine it's a it's a
second that that like like [__] is
introduced yeah like you could have this
but you're not having it
when you're by yourself and you haven't
jerked off it's like all right
cool
you can focus more
yeah but then the second something that
it that that Jews can go into gets
around you or anything
huh or anything that looks like a female
you know yeah
yeah when you're in a stone tower on the
side of a of the ocean it's like yeah
for sure
why would I jerk off I'm thinking about
God all the time that's the only thing
going on I don't need to jizz
the holy jazz
no but yeah Christianity got [__] up
it was like because there's like there's
Kings got involved in it
like people with church of England yeah
exactly like it's Scientology
what's his name Charlemagne
I was learning about Charlemagne
he was like the he was like the church's
Army for a while he like took over like
the Catholic church he was like all
right we're gonna go [__] kill every
[__] German
y was like there Russia
yeah they're like we're gonna kill every
[__] German or make him [__] make
him Christian
what
it's a weird project
that's so weird are you planning on
eating at any point yeah before
yeah
do you wanna
eat at the club maybe we can get it for
free well we do have to stop for gas
uh at some point
yeah let's uh get some Panda Express
oh yeah
authentic what do you want to eat
oh I'm good I ate before I ate like
right before you guys came
I'm also I'm also good but I can take
you through
yeah I mean we might as well go to Panda
Express because there's probably a gas
station next to it yeah
do you like PF Changs
yeah what do you want to eat PF Chang's
Panda Express
bedroom Wok Express uh Mongolian Grill
isn't that much Asian food is that stuff
just is that stuff that you might be
interested in
this shitty Chinese food I just learned
about a Thai place that is open 24 7. in
Austin in Austin it's so good it's like
eight eight have you been traded yeah
yeah yeah it's like that where is it
it's like that yeah it's so good I ate
Thai food it was different it was like
four seven General sews Pad Thai it's
like really saucy
yeah that place is that place is weird
they got they got too many options but
it was good it's good yeah it was great
though but I think I like this type
place better what's it called uh fat
something I'll send you the other info
you don't remember how you're gonna find
it no I have it on my Instagram I just
put Thai and then it shows up fat Thai
Guy it makes you feel it's high like in
the search function 24 7 the beer the
beer there is so cold it's good
I went there at like 2 A.M
on Sunday
where is it by you it's like South South
yeah they also have another location in
uh Burnett Road or something
[Music]
are they like uh living in that like
apartment complex like apart from
you know civilization that's nice
can you walk anywhere
you talking about me yeah
uh there's a park really close by
uh I guess you're close to the airport
the airport's probably like 10 minutes
yeah it's like yeah it's like eight holy
[__] air force close I mean anything
that's you can I mean there's like bars
and stuff
nearby
you could walk to but uh
it's just easier to I mean it's also
just like a 10 minute drive to downtown
so it's that's awesome yeah they're
doing stuff it's usually that
you know it's across the river you can
just go on that one big road like
Seventh Street yeah you just take
seventh street right there yeah it takes
like less than 10 minutes
go to you can go to ladybird Lake that's
also like 10 15.
Frozen
what else could I need
do you like the east side because
I know the other house you're at was on
the east side as well
yeah he starts chill it's uh
it's a
yeah it's just I mean it's just like
neighborhood people
yeah so
it seems like there's not a lot of
things happening but a lot of people
live there but there's not like
it's not like downtown or anything or
the domain like they don't have anything
really
yeah like the domain is like it's got
all the stuff but it's like wow I was
like I don't want to live in a mall
yeah just people walking by every day
yeah it's like people that lived I was
like I don't wanna I wouldn't want to
live downtown
but living near downtown is cool
and they don't even have a car how do
you get there do you just take an Uber
yeah like Uber or get a ride with
somebody you'd ever take the bus
uh I haven't taken the bus it's covered
it kind of suck now
yeah
well I thought you used to have a car
what happened to the car
uh I got it I got it shipped to Colleen
I got some teenage Mexicans working on
it
go ahead I gotta I my dad works at a
at like a like a career center
like for like high school kids oh my God
like high school kids that want to like
do like Automotive stuff they sacrifice
your car for their education yeah I just
gotta win but I gave it to him on uh I
forgot it was right before spring break
so they're not even there I don't know
are you afraid they're gonna bring
illegal immigrants I was thinking they
put like hydraulics on it that'd be sick
using your plate and you get in trouble
so yeah
are you are you scared they're gonna do
any illegal activity in your car and you
have to replay it and they think it's
you that brought the Mexicans over the
Border I don't care no as long as it
works
that's cool you're gonna get like an
awesome cards
nice
all day in Texas
oh yeah dude I went to a I went to a
safari in Johnson City
just some just some people that just
bought a bunch of exotic animals and
they just you just
they just drive you around on a tractor
and you get to see them all
just the craziest like the enclosures
aren't even like that put together that
there's like I went there and there was
a lemur on the outside of the cage
and I was like trying I was like hey
your lemur escaped and they're like oh
oh the Lemur oh yeah he gets out
sometime
I was just like this lever is like
walking towards me
the boundary between human and animal
needs to be really like strongly guarded
in a zoo I would think like
yeah I was like I kind of like this
better it's just like
you're in it
yeah it's just like yeah dude there's no
there's no like uh I feel like zoos they
still try to trick you and the thing
it's like no it's a wild animal
he's just sleeping right now but he's a
wild animal
but that place they're like no they they
don't go anywhere because we give them
free food
yeah it's like a cooperative
yeah it's like just look at him dude
stop being stop being like why do you
need it to be like
vicious
you know yeah you're getting to look at
a cool animal Jesus what else do you
need
have you ever seen a water buffalo
before it got damn
well it's not like doing anything it's
like shut up dude it's right there
some animals are good in captivity and
some animals are
are horrific
yeah they had a lot of like uh like uh
like like herbivores
so Bros I feel like zebras would be
chill yeah just animals are like that
are happy to be safe yeah they're just
like this is cool
yeah animals that are like yummy
yeah yeah animals that yeah it's like no
yeah our life used to uh life kind of
sucks for us kind of yeah
yeah I wonder what that's like because
like their whole culture is based on
fear and who can run away the quickest
and then if you take that away
like what happened it's like a welfare
state it's like they're not motivated
anymore they're gonna yeah but all they
did was eat anyways but I think that
that's what happened to humans too you
know
we used to be very afraid
well I feel like we're still pretty
vicious to each other economically you
know
[Music]
yeah but we also used to be poor
it's it's kind of like every most people
were poor
and now it's like you can be
now you can like [__] over people and
get and be not poor
I feel like back in like when everybody
was like
hunter-gatherers or stuff you know it's
like
it's like all right everybody's kind of
poor
yeah we should be you know let's be
chill now it's like harder or easier to
go yeah now now you can now you can [__]
over somebody like in a different state
you know and get rich so it's like way
less accountability yeah you know it's
like you can start an online business
selling like like scamming people
and like people from like people you
don't know are buying into it like you
know bite into your fake crypto you just
[__] over a [__] ton of people that
you've never seen before and get rich as
[__] that's way easier to fall into that
trap than it is to like if you're living
in a village of 10 people
and be like hey guys here's my
here's my new bone here's the new bone
invention
oh yeah let's get on board with that and
it's like I scammed you guys they'd all
just be like [__] you we're gonna kill
you
you piece of [__] yeah
so we're still able to be like vicious
in our own ways
but like animals yeah I feel like back
then it's like you had to you had to be
vicious outwards
you had to be you had to be like all
right I'm gonna gain my success by going
[__] crazy on a deer
you know yeah or kill I'm gonna kill a
[__] lion and then everybody's gonna
be like whoa
but you couldn't really do that inward
because then it's like just sit on a
computer and press buttons and then do
evil that way
yeah right
yeah it's way easier to be
okay yeah because there's no like acts
associated with it it's like if you
are like uh eating uh
food and getting your vitamins that way
as opposed to just taking a little pill
that has all the vitamins in it it's
like easier to take the pill
but eating the the steak has like other
stuff in it and like it works out your
jaws and stuff so it's like
you're you're
associating vitamins with other things
but if you just get the pure vitamins
then it's like you could overdose on it
quickly
yeah I think it's it's more just like
it's it's more just like there's there's
less accountability like you can like if
you if you uh
like you know [__] kill somebody and
rape somebody in a small village
then you then they'd kick you out of the
village and you have to live in the wild
by yourself
you know yeah yeah like you're just
I think that would probably kill you
yeah or they'd kill you yeah they
wouldn't tell you just go with
it okay or just if you did something
small I guess if you were just the most
annoying guy that'd just be like all
right
you can't live in our village
so I heard like back then they didn't
know who the father was because
everybody was kind of like [__] each
other
like other females
so if you were a man you were the Father
Figure to all the kids
but then obviously the mother who knew
who who's a child
so the mother was the motherboard if you
were a man you were a father to all the
kids
that's pretty cool yeah pretty cool and
everyone looked the same because they're
all pretty safe yeah so no one knew
except there's like one really hot guy
and all the kids look like him and he's
like that's not my [__] game I don't
think they were going for hot the strong
guy though that's what I mean yeah hot
man hot was different than the big fat
strong guy yeah
inside yeah someone's semen is like too
powerful that guy that Guy brought a
tiger and he made me a coat he couldn't
[__] him yeah
[Music]
I think like a lot of people
don't know what happened back then oh
yeah I know we like try to make sense
imagine what happened it makes sense of
the entire thing
but I think uh
it's crazy how easily we forget
like it should be some way to remember
because we're only going to be alive for
a few more years
what
I mean compared to like the for how long
humans have been alive
you think the world's gonna end soon no
for us we're gonna die
why'd you say a few years though because
compared to the size of the amount of
years that Humanity has existed it's
nothing
oh that's true yeah but to us as humans
a few years it's like three or four
Jesus was here only 2023 years ago or
whatever
that's nothing
but don't you think like uh
we can't figure out what happened back
then if we just sort of
put someone in that situation or we run
like an AI model I feel like yeah I feel
like there's like weird dude I got like
weird conspiracy thing about like
archeology and like anthropology stuff
because it's like I feel the same way
I'm like why don't we know more you know
yeah it's like I feel like they're not
really looking
yeah they just want to see what they
want to see they're like oh our way is
the best and let's see how these other
people lived
they're like biased
yeah because I always feel like
everybody says it was like oh no it was
way worse back then it's like was it
because they were still doing it I mean
it couldn't have been that bad they did
it forever
yeah why would we be so miserable right
now
if this was normal like this misery or
like I think that they were closer to
danger but they were happier because
there was like more family more like
Adventure going on I think if you are in
fear of like survival
there's no
there's no room for depression you have
to be active you have to be moving you
have to be looking for your family
finding food you're not like sitting on
your couch you know scrolling through
Tick Tock and then it's like oh I feel
sad yeah when I walked into two days how
much scarier is a lion attack than than
that kid you knew coming into the school
with a AK-47 you know what I mean like
is a lion attack that much scarier it's
like didn't that didn't that kid that
you thought you were friends with
blowing the people's you knows heads off
you know it's like
I don't know I don't think it could be
yeah we probably feel some of the same
emotions
all right well I'm gonna stop the
podcast